تقولون بان هذا البرنامج تقيم الاضرار
لتزايد قروض البابونج وايجاد الحلول يسير
وفقا الخطه الموضوع وبدعم حكومي وشراكه من
جميع الجهات ما هي النتائج اللي وصلت لك
لن
ترتاحات في كامل المناطق المتضرره في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي بالمناسبه
سته مناطق تمتد من اقصى الجنوب غرب
المملكه الى منطقه المدينه المنوره تم رصد
همم اكثر من 500 بؤره لمشاكل القرود
البابونج المستانس وتداخله مع المناطق
السكنيه والمناطق الزراعيه وتم تثبيت اكثر
من 300 لوحه توعويه ل- اا توعيه المقيمين
والسواح اللي عندهم اطعامها لان الاطعام
هو احد العناصر الاساسيه
لجذبها من المناطق البريه وتحويل سلوكها
وايضا همم عامل مؤثر حتى في فسيولوجيه
التكاثر وزياده الاعداء كذلك تم الاستجابه
ضمن هذا ال- ال- المرحله الاولى من
البرنامج همم الى اكثر من 2000 بلاغ وتمت
همم كما اسلفت همم اقامه خمسه حملات
توعويه بالاضافه التي حملت توعويه مع
الشركاء في المناطق العقاريه
واعداد القروض ايضا تزيد وتتضاعف
المرحله الثانيه يا استاذ خالد اللي تبدا
من
20-23 هذا العام ان شاء الله
ستنطلق اعمال المعالجات الجذريه للمشكله
لان المرحله الاولى كانت تتضمن همم تطبيق
التجريبي لافضل الحلول وافضل الممارسات
للمعالجه على المستوى الدولي وهذا تم همم
في عديد من المناطق ااا اليوم نحن
بانتظار ان شاء الله انطلاق ال ال في مطلع
20 23 خلال الاسابيع القادمه بحول الله
اطلاق المرحله الثانيه من برنامج وهي
المرحله المعنيه بالحلول الجذريه ولكن
نريد ان انوه ان الحلول الجذريه تحتاج الى
تعاون من السكر
التعاون وقصه هذه الحلول الكلام هذا
الدكتور احمد احنا نسمع وصلنا عقود يعني
انا اكثر من 40 سنه وانا عارف المشكله هذه
خلال عمل خلال فترات كذلك حافظ مثل هذه
التصريحات خلال الفتره اللي راحت فين 2013
كانت لك تصريحات دكتور احمد حول هذه القصه
يعني ونفس الكلام اللي صار حتى الان وحزنا
من الحلول لمواجهه مشكلات التجمعات قروض
البابونج في السعوديه
واستراتيجيات وغيرها من الامور تكرر الامر
في 2014 وعقدتم ورش عاما منها في جامعه
الملك خالد وتكلمتوا عن حلول بعيده المدى
وقصيره المدى وغيرها من الامور اخرها كان
في 2019 كمان كان لكم تصريحات على لسانكم
وعلى لسان كذلك نائب رئيس الهيئه الدكتور
هاني محمد الطوالي عن نفس الموضوع احنا
ليش عندنا هذه المشكله ما تنحل ليش نحتاج
كل هذه السنين لعقد الورش
لقاءات في الجامعات وخبراء عالميه وخلال
هذه السنوات كلها بدون ان نرى نتيجه على
ارضها واسمح لي هنا اقول لك وجهه نظر
البعض انه هذا ما تقوم به هو مجرد رد فعل
يعني بمعنى تحصل حادث
لمداهمه قرود لمش في اي منطقه تطلع
فيديوهات تطلع لكم تصاريح لكن على ارض
الواقع ليس هناك اي حلول لهذه المشكله رغم
كثره اللجانات اللجان والاجتماعات وغيرهم
طيب
ما عمل بالسابق من دراسات ومن همم ورش عمل
وغيرها في هذه المشكله لم يكن هناك اي رصد
لاي مبالغ للمعالجات نحن نتحدث عن مرحله
واقعيه او عمليه مجرد بس كده همم
لمعالجه المشكله اليوم الوضع اختلف هناك
ميزانيه
لتقييم الوضع على همم على الارض الورقه من
الوضع من هذا من زمان دكتور احمد انتم هذه
المعلومات اليوم توصلت لها من البرنامج
الاخير انتم عارفينها صار لكم سنوات
بالتالي ليش انتم كمان ترجعوا تعملوا
دراسات وابحاث وخبراء على اساس توصلوا نفس
النتيجه اللي وصلت لها قبل 10 او 15 او 20
سنه ليش ما تبدا بمرحله
يعني نعم السبب استاذ خالد هو انه لابد في
اي مشكله من معرفه خط الاساس ما لم يكن خط
الاساس واضحا لا يمكن ان تقيم مدى عملك
التقييمات السابقه يمكن كما تفضلت هذه
المشكله عمرها اكثر من اربعه عقود انا
شخصيا عملت في هذه المشكله منذ عام
1988 منذ عملي همم في همم
قطاع الحياه الفطريه همم
والاعمال السابقه القديمه تغيرت كثيرا همم
في الوقت الحالي مع الاسف همم المشكله همم
وتصاعدت في المناطق الزراعيه والمناطق
السكنيه واهلنا في الجنوب همم
في المناطق المتضرره يعانون كثيرا والالم
الذي يشعرون به نحن ايضا نشعر به ولكن همم
اليوم نحن في مرحله مختلفه تماما من اجل
الطلاق الحلول همم حزمه الحلول التي اوصت
بها الدراسات
اليوم الحلول حزمه حلول لا تقتصر على خفض
الاعداد في المناطق المتضخمه فيها الاعداد
ولكن يشتمل ذلك على همم ايضا عمليات
التعقيم ويشتمل ذلك ايضا على عمليات
الابعاد ويشتمل ذلك ايضا على برامج
التوعيه البيئيه حتى لا تعود المشكله الى
سكرتي يعني خلص الناس اقصد ابداوا في
القضاء عليها يعني بالقتل الرحيم
بالطرق المعالجه اللي ذكرتها انت قبل 10
سنوات
فكره القضاء عليها هذا ليس حل اذا كانت
الاسباب المؤديه الى المشكله لا زالت
قائمه
وكمان تقول المواطن لانه هذا مو مبرر انه
اذا كان المواطن هو سبب في في زيادتها انه
نخليها تتفشل
هذا المواطن
جزء يقع على عاتق
المواطن وعلى عاقل الموافق
صحيح وهو صحيح وهو صحيح ما هو مبرر انه
تتفاق من المشكله الى هذا الحد ويجلس
حاطين على خدنا ويقول والله المواطنه هذه
معروفه
اكرمكم الله همم
النفايات الغذائيه اجلكم الله همم سواء
كانت همم على الطرق العامه كثير من الناس
اتكلم عن تاريخ معين فتره زمنيه محدده
نقول انه هذه المشكله خلاص
الى حد معين او انها انتهت ولا لا زال
هناك عدم تعاون بعض الجهات همم او غيرها
من الاسباب اللي تمنع عن معالجه هذه
المركز الوطني على تواصل مع عديد من
الجهاز
المتضرره وايضا الامانه في هذه المناطق
وغيرها من الجهات المعنيه في معالجه
المشكله انطلاق الحلول الجذريه سيبدا ان
شاء الله هذا العام 20 23 ولكن كما اسلفت
اخفض الاعداد هذا ليس حل همم النهائي خفض
الاعداد مع استمرار تقديم الاطعمه لها
بشكل مباشر وشكل غير مباشر وترك حاويه
النفايات تكرر اكرمكم الله
النفايات الغذائيه بالذات على جوانب الطرق
يعني جذب المزيد من المجموعات البريه
وتحويل السلوكها الى سلوك مستانس